well I'm sorry care we like it yeah oh
well just checking for language a lot to
use like the f-word or like absolute
gotta keep it very pg-13 anything you
want
and on that be careful on that but on
that note let me say I'm pleased to be
joined by Steve Bernal known to many of
you as as destiny or what's the
difference between destiny and Omni
destiny is it like first lame name last
name or no God no I just
I picked destiny as a name like million
years ago when I was a kid or it was
like the culmination of a ton of
different ideas and then I just kind of
stuck throw it all my gaming stuff got
up and then yeah I'm needing just for
right because I can't get the destiny
tag on Twitter so how many sounded
pretentious enough to throw on there so
that that's your background right I mean
it seems like from from my research of
you it seems like you kind of started in
the video game live-streaming world and
then kind of got more involved in
politics and and some of the debates
that you've done yeah I've always kind
of I've always been like a like a video
game streamer is what I do but I've
always had an interest and other topics
as well um like we've talked about all
sorts of stuff of my stream ethics and
biology and philosophy and science stuff
and all sorts of stuff and then around
the 2016 election season obviously we
you know political stuff picked up a lot
more and then I kind of started to
become more active when I saw what the
political scene on YouTube looked like I
know how do you describe your politics
I actually don't I try not to use labels
anymore I guess like if you if I had to
you would call me like I guess in
America you probably call me centered
left in Europe you'd call me
center-right but I try to just go by
individual positions because it seems
these days that the political labeling
is just a nightmare even like saying all
right or whatever can confer a wide
range of beliefs on people that they
might not necessarily agree whether or
not I am is there like an American
politician that you'd say kind of lines
up with your worldview definitely not
don't think so
I really like so like Francis I really
liked Bernie because I liked the
corporate finance stuff like getting
most of that out of politics I think
it's really important the lobbying stuff
is really disgusting but I am an artist
supporter of capitalism I very much
believe in free trade I do not like
Bernie's stance on like protectionism
and whatnot I think that lines up with
Trump's protectionist ideas quite a bit
I don't know
Hardcore Bernie would have been with
that but um yeah yeah I mean it's this
kind of weird thing where there's this
guy Federico Federico Finkelstein who
teaches that at the new school and he's
like an expert on populism and it was
interesting how he did a pretty
interesting analysis of how Trump and
Bernie both had sort of like populist
sounding rhetoric but on the
implementation that we're seeing and
that we would have seen under Bernie
would have been drastically different
and like it's it's fascinating to me
because the populist rhetoric actually
had pretty broad appeal but they would
have been drastically different
implementations of that rhetoric yeah
for sure yeah you could go in yeah yeah
they were very very very different I
don't know if populism is is enough to
describe yeah the vast differences
between the two or or that could mean
well I guess this kind of gets into you
know what I was complaining about
earlier as far as political labels go
right where if you say something this is
why I don't use anymore if you call
somebody a label you have to spend the
next five minutes clarifying you know
what they believe in anyway so thank you
you've seemed to debate a bunch of the
people that are and again I don't want
to label them but there's kind of if
you've imagined this Venn diagram of all
these terms like alright aunt is JW
men's rights activist has some overlap
there's like you know you can picture
you can just use cancer I think where
exposure but you know the other you've
debated a lot of these people do you
debate them because you enjoy the debate
or because you want to actually try to
sort of prove them wrong or change the
minds of their audience like what's the
objective with those debates there's a
lot that goes into it it's it's a
multi-faceted thing on one hand it
really bothers me that this side of the
political aisle has so ardently like
grabbed on to this feels versus reals
kind of like slogan like where they
always talk about how they have like all
the facts on their side and then the
other side is a bunch of you know crying
sjw blue haired women that they find on
tumblr and whatnot when most of their
arguments are completely rooted in
emotion you know like anytime you do an
immigration argument you're always going
to drill back to the fact that they're
scared of brown people or they want to
preserve some ambiguous definition of
Western white culture or whatever the
[ __ ] that means
yeah just saw so much of that so much of
that
is unfounded in any fact-based argument
whatsoever so it bothers me that so many
of them act like they're there holding
up some fact-based platform when when
most of the research on almost every
issue they talk about doesn't back
anything they're you know you've got
people talking about deals versus reels
who are on Iran eclis citing project
Veritas reports and [ __ ] like this is
not possible like you know you could
call CNN fake news on one hand and then
you're throwing Breitbart and Daily
Caller links at me in the next breath
like you can't possibly believe this
it's insane well one of them one of
along those lines I did a piece on the
alt-right a couple months ago and it's
interesting to me how there's this
projection that happens where they are
against toxic identity politics but it's
effectively an identity movement the
alt-right movement and I think that what
you're pointing out applies to a lot of
these movements where they kind of
embody what it is that they claim to be
against in a way don't they kind of so
this is why I don't like to use labels
anymore because there are people in the
alt-right that would take issue with
what you just said so you so your claim
here is that all right people attack
identitarian x' and they say that
identitarian ism is bad technically i'm
pretty sure if you talk to most people
only alright they would say well no we
actually are an identity Rhian movement
and we appreciate identitarian x' their
argument would be something along the
lines of like we appreciate the jewish
people look out for themselves and the
black people that got for themselves all
we want is to create a world where white
people can look out for the well I've
interviewed Richard Spencer and that's
exactly what he said word for word but
there he said he's not an identity Rhian
no he said he says he is and exactly
that he and white shoes want their place
and black identity is important but he
just thinks it would be better for
everybody to kind of be separate they go
to the wrong yeah to kind of do their
own thing are you concerned I mean it's
in the world you and I are in it's it
can be kind of deceptive sometimes to
really accurately assess the sum total
impact of some of these movements but I
this might be sort of like a naive
optimism of mine but I am sort of
thinking that that movement those
movements disproportionately are loud on
the internet but they actually don't
represent that significant a portion of
the u.s. well what's your sense of that
I hope that's
true I would hope that that's true but
when people like Bannon we're so far
into the White House and whatnot and
when people like Milo and Ben Shapiro
are getting Ben Shapiro is not alright
to be cleared up here like mildly
innopolis and should are getting you
know international coverage to some
extent for some of the things they're
involved in that stuff is kind of
worrying however I'm not going to make
the same leap that the people on the
right do when they say that crazy
leftists are taking over colleges you
know I'm not gonna sit here and tell you
that the alt-right is like this
mainstream political ideology or
anything I really don't think it is at
this point I think that scares me is
just that I think that it's really easy
I think it's really easy to take
somebody that's like a big trumple and
and move them over onto an all-right
platform because all of their if you
have like this fundamental belief this
fundamental philosophical belief you can
build off of it all of these positions
and even though their underlying
philosophical beliefs are different the
the the policy positions are very
similar of both of these groups of
people so I guess an example of that if
I take a race realist and we talk about
immigration you know the race realist
would say okay well I want to protect
right white culture I don't want white
people to become a minority so we need
to get rid of the Browns the blacks the
Muslims whatever you know get rid of all
these people well if I look at somebody
like Trump he wants to ban all the
Muslims coming into the country we want
to build a big wall to keep Hispanics
out we're okay with terrorizing the
colored people here right we don't like
Browns with Chef Arpaio we support
things like stop and frisk you know so
it's like all of the policy positions
line up perfectly so taking a person
that believes in those and then just
saying like hey do you think that may be
the reason why we have problems with all
these you know brown people is because
there's a genetic reason I don't think
it would be that hard to do it and
that's kind of what worries me you
brought up now we both brought up
identity politics and identitarian ISM a
couple times what's your assessment of
or just put in a different way are you
at all concerned with the way in which
identity politics is used by the
Democratic Party to try to win elections
sometimes successfully sometimes not or
what kind of where what's your general
sense of that issue I guess so this has
been a massive failing of Democrats and
my biggest criticism of that party is in
the way that they do their messaging and
so far is this kind of
insofar as identity politics goes this
is so this is the way that I explain
this when you when you're looking at
people in the United States you you have
to look at them by class right this is
how we do analyses of large groups of
people we're not looking at individuals
it's just doesn't make any sense you
can't do that you know you look at large
classes of people so when you ask
questions like what is the power of a
white person to be racist to a black
person oftentimes you're looking at
large structures you know how does the
criminal justice system work how does
our employment system work you know what
studies can we point to to prove or
disprove the impacts of racism the
problem that people on the Left have is
they will take these these very accurate
assessments of classes and they will
expect an individual to interpret that
as reality when that's not what
individuals don't interpret things as
classes so for instance if I go on
Twitter and I put out hashtag white
genocide or something you know or if I
say like you know white people are
oppressing black people that might be
true when kind of like an academic sense
and like an overall sense of white
versus black in the United States but
any individual white person that reads
that is never going to be on board with
your message they're gonna look at it
they're gonna go well I've never been
racist against a black person why are
you trying to saddle an entire class is
worth the problems unto me as an
individual and I think a lot of people
get lost in that messaging there when
they feel like they're being attacked
for crimes that they didn't commit I
think that that also connects to I mean
the right for a long time and anybody
who's familiar with like George Lake
offs work would understand this pretty
deeply I think that the right has been
really good when it comes to framing
messaging and vocabulary and I mean you
know the the use of SJW as a pejorative
at this point what's wrong with being
maybe not a warrior but a fighter for an
advocate for social justice really
nothing right but the term social
justice warrior now is sort of riddled
with connotations and it's become a
really good way to immediately try to
kind of deflate somebody and attack
their credibility
I think identity politics is similar
insofar as Bill Clinton used identity
politics and I would argue very
successfully he did it in a very
different way than what I think some are
critical of the Democratic Party of
having done in the last five years but
identity politics per se I don't think
is actually the issue I think it's more
how do you address issues of identity
do you do it in a way that is inclusive
or feels exclusive and those are the
details that kind of disappear when the
write successfully turns these terms
into a pejorative I don't know what if
you agree with that I mean yeah I'd like
it this is a really hard one because
it's like the the problem is it to man
if you would have talked to me a year
ago I would've been totally different
less I've lost so much faith in humanity
over the past year of talking to these
absolute like morons oh my god the
problem is that defending the position
and I'll say on the left in general is
so much harder than defending the
position on the right because the right
ironically enough usually appeals
towards your feelings and it's very hard
to beat these kind of anecdotal appeals
or these appeals to emotion when someone
on the right says don't you feel like
you're getting [ __ ] by the system you
know don't you feel like everybody's out
to get you don't you feel yeah I hate to
make the comparison but if you watch
like the ISIS propaganda videos they
read you know very similarly to a lot of
the all right recruitment stuff you know
don't you feel like you don't have a
place in society all the Liberals are
out to get you blah blah blah the
messaging there is super easy super
slick it makes you feel included it
feels awesome there's not as much
infighting on the right not any nowhere
near as much as compared to the left now
look at look at the Al Franken had to I
think he's officially resigned right
from Congress or he's put in his
resignation yeah I think his last day
was like Judd the third of them sure the
[ __ ] RNC threw their support back
behind Roy Moore in the Alabama election
and Trump is still in there no one even
bats an eye at that stuff you know
Republicans are ruthless when it comes
to politics and Democrats are so
concerned always and I don't mean this
negatively maybe this is important you
know in trying to be you know morally
correct or morally righteous and whatnot
but Republicans are the efficacy of
their political movements is brutal its
ruthless you know their messaging is
very simple all of their ideas are very
easy to defend and anytime you want to
attack something on the left you know
it's or you or if you're on the left and
you want to attack right-leaning idea
those arguments are all really [ __ ]
complicated their very idea to defend
I'm glad you're bringing this up because
I last semester I had the pleasure and
also the shock of actually going through
the work of doing it of teaching as an
adjunct at a college here in the Boston
area
and I talked about the sort of
structural advantage that the right has
on a lot of issues and I it's to it two
examples I think are really sort of
demonstrative or illustrative of the
issue is for example taxes right the
argument right is a very simple one
which is it's your money you should keep
it
that is so succinct pithy and effective
whereas the argument on the left isn't
the opposite it's not hey it's the
government's money so your tax rate
should be as high as possible it's well
we all have feel entitled to the money
we've earned but we have to realize that
to have a basic standard of living the
government does need you've already lost
right because it yeah all right you're
already ended your messaging yeah of
course yeah you know well technically
the money that you earn could be you
know you could earn more money if more
people are doing successful in the
United States and if you've got more
money going to education you've got a
larger consumer base like yeah you're
getting bogged down in these arguments
like you're already lost like passed
like the first sentence are you familiar
with them sargon of akkad yes I referred
to him as Karl Benjamin myself okay but
that's an actual I for whatever reason
ruggle to even accept that his name is
sorry okay yeah sure that might even
rival Omni destiny in terms of it's like
a great example with him is I've had two
very long conversations them are you
familiar with Ben Shapiro's three big
talking points on how to make it to the
middle class
my dad's I've not heard that okay Hugh
these parroted a lot one is like I think
one is get married before having kids
too or don't have a kid in college two
is like get a job out of high school and
then three is something there I remember
that they remember these like three
really basic points and you know and
they sound really good but people never
realize that there's so much baked into
all of these so for instance you know
like um like don't have a kid in high
school well you know if you're wealthy
the chances of that happening are much
less because for a variety of reasons
you know for no other reason because you
can afford an abortion if you're 16 15
years old and you're in a you know
wealthy family you can abortion all you
want you've also got greater access to
contraception you also probably have
more things to do than just [ __ ] people
right like you know poor people tend to
have not as much access to luxury things
I'm not as much access to
extracurriculars etc etc you know I say
we you know you default to a lot of
other stuff
but I remember my conversation with Carl
we got into this big debate on on on
black people in the United States and on
the I'm kind of like the economic and
social plight of the black person in the
United States and like his go-to
argument for everything was you know if
the family if the family unit was strong
you know black people would be doing so
much better which I agree with of course
so then he's like well black people just
need to get married and I'm like well
it's not that simple Carl you know
people don't just make decisions to get
married there's a lot of prerequisites
for that and then Carl on ironically
will scream at me where is the law that
keeps black people from getting married
and it's like [ __ ] it nothing works that
way you know we're like where's the law
that keeps women from working in
colleges or getting certain jobs like
there's a basic I mean that it actually
that connects to just a fundamental
logical fallacy which is just because
you might be able to correlate getting
married before having kids with being in
the middle class you don't enter the
middle class oh I think we've outside we
just lost you for a second there you
don't enter the middle class just
because of when you get married right
it's it's a it's a standard text logical
fallacy if finding a financial success
is is oftentimes a prerequisite towards
getting married and this isn't even a
controversial position you can you can
if you're in chat right now you just
google like marriage wealthy people and
you'll see they're like oh it seems like
marriage is generally something that
only wealthy people do right then
yeah marriage is a symptom of success
not a cause of it but to poor people
getting married won't make them
successful that's not how that works so
how any of it works the other example I
was going to bring up and I mean better
it's sort of similar to the tax was you
know abortion right I mean hey after
conception into life and abortion is
murder clear simple every but you could
agree or disagree but everybody gets
that the the position on the Left isn't
kill kids up until they're 18 right I
mean it's not the opposite that it's
well you know it's more complicated than
that and exactly when does it become a
late term abortion you've lost with a
lot of people already for sure you know
tip it for our full disclosure I'm
actually pro-life for that reason but I
don't think I would ever make it illegal
that's a whole other topic but no but I
agree that that argument is very
difficult to have yeah I and you know
it's funny you mention that because I'm
I'm pro-choice but I don't want people
to be in positions where they need to
have abortion
right yeah that's my big thing like I'm
very much pro-life because I don't want
abortion stick to happen how can you be
pro-life but then like anti-sex IDI anti
access to contraception exactly how do
you how do you how do you reconcile
these positions in your mind
ah yeah absolutely hey how do you um how
do you deal with I mean I think I'm
guessing you probably are the target of
at least some anti-semitism online
apparently I just became Jewish a couple
weeks ago and in a fight that I had with
somebody else
apparently everybody thinks I'm actually
Jewish now so that's like anything I've
been doing but and so but what what is
like do you how do you identify
religiously I'm very much atheist very
strongly it yes are you car you
ethnically Jewish
no I'm theirs I'm not I'm not no you're
not okay so I'm just like I read online
that you were Jewish maybe somebody got
to there you go that's how a lot of
people think I'm like uh ironically
Jewish now which is a big part of the
alt-right platform is um talking about
the Jewish Question the idea that the
Jews are all in control of the meeting
everything yeah that's okay well show
anyway will score yeah the Jewish people
being control of everything is a major
problem is that no I think that the pre
the problem of people believing that is
the problem no but I mean more generally
like I recently had a conversation with
my audience about should I even waste
time on Twitter and YouTube kind of
engaging with with trolls and YouTube
drama and all this type of stuff and you
seem to like to mix it up to some degree
I mean is that is that again similar
question to the debating is it because
you enjoy it is it because any publicity
is good publicity is it merely to try to
get under under people's skin do you
have a lot of free time on your hands
um so I feel like so the big thing that
I've always had is that it seems like
left-leaning people are oftentimes
pretty scared to engage right-leaning
people for a variety of reasons I've had
a really I don't want scene like I don't
like talk it out but I've had a pretty
hardcore like background on the internet
like I've spent a lot of time doing a
lot of crazy [ __ ] on the internet for a
decent amount of time so I think that
I'm pretty uniquely built to kind of
engage these sorts of people in
conversation such that a lot of people
on the left in terms of YouTube politics
aren't really comfortable doing it you
know I
to some extent Ravel in jumping
into the [ __ ] show because I you know
it's the some extent it is entertaining
to me in terms of like goals I kind of
have like I always say that I have two
goals I kind of have three now I guess
like I just want people to be having
fact-based conversations that like so
when you're talking about things we're
talking about real things so for
instance we can talk about the rise in
immigrant crime in Europe
without saying that Sweden is literally
on fire you know like that's a
conversation that's possible to have and
then make sure that people are making
like reasonable or realistic arguments
so for instance if you're trying to say
that we need to do everything we can to
improve the economy you can in the next
hand say that we need to stop all
immigration because those two things fly
right in the face of one another and
then kind of like my third thing now I
guess is that typically what I'm aiming
for when I have these conversations is
very clear that I'm never budging the
demagogues on the other side
I'm usually aiming for the people in the
middle I call it like the 40-40-20 thing
where like 40% of both sides are dug in
everybody that watches me that's my huge
fan is always going to get crushed every
debate regardless of whether I perform
well or not 40% you know on the other
side are always going to say that but
there's this 20% in the middle that I
legitimately find or on the fence who
will come over to my side after I've had
these conversations and I get tons of
emails from people that used to be huge
sargon fans huge stefan molyneux fans
fans of all of these really crazy people
online who will say like oh hey desk you
know I heard a lot of bad things about
you and then I saw you had a
conversation with you know insert my
idol on YouTube here and wow you know
you sounded really articulate and you
brought up a lot of really good
arguments and I appreciate that and I'm
kind of moving more towards your
direction I get a lot of those kinds of
emails which feel really good so I'm
actually considered the thing that you
know we you can engage or not with this
person that person antagonist just
random people on Twitter whatever I
actually am genuinely scared by the
number of people that are following some
of these I don't even know what to call
them right like idiots I just say stupid
some are stupid where they're sort of
like they fall for the I guess it's the
delivery and the sometimes pseudo
eloquence or articulate nature of people
it's the messaging the maybe maybe it is
the narrative sometimes I think the
messaging quite frankly isn't that good
and they sometimes don't realize they
might be following people who
believe absolutely outrageous things
that you would you would be borderline
referred to a mental health professional
for believing and they can sort of put
that aside because they find either like
you're saying the messaging interesting
or they like the delivery or whatever
the case may be and that's really the
group I'm scared of where like I wonder
you know if people if there's this many
people kind of out in the world with
these outrageous beliefs that have no
connection to facts at all then this has
implications in the economy it has
implications ellaktor lee and i think
obviously we're seeing that it's it's
just downright scary to me well yeah i
mean imagine a world where we get people
that are all kind of like moving towards
a certain direction because of
propaganda and we leave something
incredibly important important up to
like a referendum that might determine
like the future of your country and
maybe you're standing in like a really
large body like the european union like
that would be horrible you know how do
you um I mean how do you so that's an
actually an interesting one because I
talk a lot on my program about we want
no not about brexit at all actually
about we want the legislative agenda of
our elected officials to reflect the
desires of the constituency and we see
that with a lot of issues that doesn't
happen net neutrality is a good example
who was for repealing net neutrality
very very few people but somehow it's
something that just kind of happened
and we're sort of looking the other way
yeah Democrats are trying to reverse it
but it's not going to happen on the
other hand there's the concern that if
you do leave the legislation to the
people and have it closely reflect what
people want people want some pretty
crazy stuff pretty often so I just sort
of don't know how to make sense of that
how to put those two together in terms
of a sort of policy or ideology do you
are you worried about that idea at this
point I've talked to so many people I'm
not good to talk to you about this
because I have lost all faith in
democracy I don't know I guess like
trying to give like a more balanced
answer I guess this is kind of the the
way that the United States government is
set up right we have the House of
Representatives which is modeled after
population in the United States so what
most people want and then we have the
Senate that's kind of there to to be
more equal
reflective of each individual state and
then we have the Supreme Court to serve
as a counterbalance to the fundamental
constitutional rights that we hopefully
ensure that every citizen so like I
guess I would kind of hope that that
balance of power kind of works to make
sure that we're not moving in a
direction that screws over or you know
certain groups of people but yeah how
are you feeling about that you think
it's working yeah I think we've moved in
better directions over time it's easy to
get lost I try to I try to maintain some
level of optimism but I mean like we've
you know gay marriage is legalized we've
overturned a lot of like bad voter [ __ ]
I think gerrymandering in North Carolina
is being looked at now as well yeah I
hope that we continue to move in a more
progressive direction I think that the
Trump stuff is probably good hopefully
it serves as a big wake-up call to
people on the left that they need to
work on improving the messaging and that
we need to be more vigilant about you
know how we address people on the right
since our messaging before was
absolutely deplorable you might say but
is there a particular issue where you
think that the left would most benefit
from better messaging is it like a
particular economic issue social
whatever really like a particular area
of opportunity so populism works in my
opinion because negativity sells much
better than positivity this is just like
a fact of the media right like it's just
just just a fact of life yeah
Bernie's message was very popular
because people do feel screwed a little
bit and he tapped into that a lot you
know Trump obviously you know taps into
it a lot I think the big kind of like
taking a step back like a general
problem is that globalism
so when you say globalism a lot of
people get a lot of really negative
thoughts in their head immediately
globalism it's been one of the most
positive impacts worldwide to every
single person on this planet like well
it's because of Alex Jones right who
says it globalism and dorable yeah sure
or or a bunch of people that do that
kind of messaging on the right but to be
fair there are some people that are
negatively impacted by globalism you
know that whole the whole Rust Belt in
the United States you know people in
Michigan people in Detroit that you know
West Virginia you can see like huge
impacts of people that are negatively
impacted by globalism you know and this
happened in United Kingdom as well you
know people that are impacted in certain
ways these people have to be addressed
you can't just pretend that they don't
exist and say well as a collective we're
doing way better you know and if you're
having an individual problem you know
get with the program which is what
Hillary tried to do
right this is why I like her slogan of
America's already great well okay now
you just completely lost everybody that
does feel a little bit [ __ ] all the
people that Bernie you know was
representing and then the people that
Trump are representing I think it's
really important as a person on the left
to acknowledge that there are some
shortcomings to the things you advocate
for and that you have to be ready to
reconcile those shortcomings or rather
to compensate the people that are
impacted by those shortcomings well that
I think also and sorry not to not to
jump in into but on that note that's why
I also think that Trump the success of
trumps call it America first or the u.s.
going it alone or whatever it's
particularly dangerous now not only
because of what you're talking about
about the the big picture benefits of
so-called global ISM but a lot of the
problems we're dealing with now one
country can't really solve right so for
sure I'm it changes an example right
what Lucien does not respect the lines
on a map for lack of putting it a
different way and they're kind of are no
nationalist solutions to that and other
problems that we're dealing with so I
think it's a particularly bad time to be
espousing that idea yeah for sure
everything about Trump's foreign
policies is just a total disaster I
don't even think we're gonna get very
far with any of it
just because I think even Republicans
would realize like anything involving
protectionism is a really [ __ ] pad
when you're export-import market when so
much of the value chains of so many of
your international companies are
exported overseas any kind of
protectionist policy is going to be a
disaster you know you start putting up
you start getting in a trade war with
China the cost of everything like tronic
good and every manufactured good in the
United States is rising twofold
you start doing trade wars with Mexico
the cost of all of your automobiles is
going up by 50 percent I'm like well
yeah these these are just really stupid
this is what I talked about when I said
like early about fact-based logical
arguments like Trump's arguments and
insofar as protectionism GAR absolutely
abysmal they're the dumbest arguments
I've ever heard in my life and they
won't help anybody what are your other
so you're against protectionism but
economically what are your other views
taxation for example is there a
particular country's economic model that
you sort of are more aligned with oh
these questions are really big and
really challenging
sure I'm basically like I guess the way
that you would summarize our uses I'm
really big on free markets I think that
markets work really well but I think you
have to acknowledge the shortcoming of
markets and what they're able to address
so for instance pollution that's an
externality that isn't accounted for in
anybody's budget sheep so there's no
reason to take into account pollution
when you run a factory why would you if
you take it into account in the person
across the street doesn't your factories
non-competitive you know but so this is
where programs like cap and trade come
in where if you find a way to make
pollution show up on a balance sheet now
you can incentivize the market to
develop a solution for it I think kind
of the problem of the Commons in a way
right then the example that people often
give is if you imagine like some common
grazing area for everybody's cattle it
works really well if everybody says you
can graze for 15 minutes a day because
otherwise there's not enough but as soon
as you have someone who says hey you
know what there's a thousand of us if I
let my cattle graze for an hour big
picture it's not a big change but I'll
be way better off unless you have
something that's going to regulate
everybody choosing to do that it's just
not going to work yeah exactly so that
you have if you're a reasonable person
you have to acknowledge that government
intervention needs to happen in some of
these things when you look at things
like health care it seems to me that
that's just not something that the free
market can provide the United States has
very unique problems in health care that
no other country in the world has and
then it seems like most other countries
in the Western world have moved to some
sort of government supported
single-payer system with a private
option or whatever you know you look at
a Canadian Canada's health care system
you look at the NHS and in the United
Kingdom like most people seem to have
the health care stuff way more figured
out than we do in the United States and
and and the the most troubling part is
that when you look at these systems that
are kind of failing us education is
another one it's not like we shortchange
it we oftentimes spend more or the most
in the world than anybody else on these
systems now I'm not even talking in
absolute values when you break it down
like a per capita or as a percentage of
GDP we spend more on things like health
care more on things like education and
we're not getting anything for it so
yeah so it seems like and when you look
at all these other countries that have
it figured out and more of like I say
leak in a socialized sense I don't know
where the government has is intervening
more on these particular markets it
seems like there are some markets that
require government intervention so when
they do then you advocate for government
intervention there with responsible
oversight
and then other things you know you leave
up to the free market we refer to let
the markets do what markets do best
which is innovate and provide solutions
to problems there's also you know the
the hypocrisy of the so-called free
market conservative or whatever who
doesn't actually seem to want a free
market in some places like for example
when it comes to energy subsidizing oil
and not alternative energy and I'm not
an absolutist really in anything right
so I'm not like but if you claim to be
something and then you so clearly or not
there needs to be some accounting for
that and that's basically unquestioned
in the u.s. I hate this talking point of
there's no difference between Democrats
and Republicans major problems with the
two-party duopoly on many issues there
really is no effective difference but on
many issues there is a difference
between them a young Republican however
on this issue I I do think that you're
you even most Democrats don't really
question the fact that the government
does play favorites and and not always
when it makes sense sure yeah which I
mean oversight is very important I'm not
gonna deny that I like being an American
are you I'm sorry are you American or
Canadian I'm actually I'm from Argentina
originally but I'm a u.s. completely
legal in my residence and living in the
United States gotcha yeah I guess just
like being an American you know I have a
fundamental hatred of the government you
know I don't want I think that if the if
it's possible for the free market and
the government to compete on anything I
think the free market will always
outperform the government it's just you
have to recognize there are some
instances where the government is the
only one that can provide you know a
solution to this problem that the free
market just can't deliver it and any
economists will tell you the same you
know these these weird and caps are
these weird guys I think that the
government is always evil you know
you know nobody legitimately takes that
position no educated person takes that
position in terms of talking about
hypocritical positions I'm only bringing
this up because I see a guy in your chat
that was talking to me earlier on
Twitter I like I see people on the on
the right will very oftentimes advocate
for these um for these positions with us
I like their very Pro free market but
then they'll go around and they'll be
very anti-immigration you know and it's
like if you talk to any true libertarian
or if you talk to any big big economics
guys any movement of or
yeah absolutely labor is a very very
integral part to any economy you always
want companies to be able to dip into
whatever labor they possibly can you
know that's the supply and you want to
increase supplies of your economy as
much as possible that's not that's not
like up for debate it's not even like a
controversy that immigration you know
yields massive economic and oftentimes
even physical benefits in the United
States so but that you'll see people say
Pro free-market and then in the next
breath talk about how they want to limit
immigration as much as possible it's
like okay well so what is your actual
value here like I said Pro free market
for white people or Pro nationalistic
more like I don't know what you're
actually saying you know you have to
wade through the [ __ ] to figure out
what they actually believe well
sometimes they don't really know right I
mean a lot of that's that's I think the
problem which is yeah not always been
fleshed out it's the repetition of
talking points that sometimes directly
conflict with each other and that that's
a difficult difficult thing to content
with where are you on I call it
constitutional fetishism which is the
crowd that sort of sees the Constitution
the way a very devout person would see a
religious text do you or I guess maybe a
good way to enter it is do you see are
you a constitutional originalist or more
of a pragmatist who thinks hey it's been
a couple hundred years the writers of
the Constitution didn't account for it's
not a perfect document that could have
accounted for every way in which the
society around it was going to change
and we need to sort of take it in
context or modify it I mean definitely
the latter but I mean I would argue that
that's how that is the original it would
be the latter right that the bit the
fact that we have the ability to amend
the Constitution I'm not really super
equipped to do this because there's a
lot of people that will get really
hardcore into like you know that strict
interpretation you have the Constitution
versus like legislating in the the
Supreme Court and whatnot so I I know
that people can go back and forth on
that I'm not usually usually when
somebody starts bringing up originalist
constitutional arguments is usually to
back up some really racist [ __ ] that's
when I've encountered it but oftentimes
those racist arguments like completely
fall flat on their face when you
actually start to question it so I like
a common when people say like well the
United States was originally a country
for white people and it's like okay well
if you want to be like super originalist
it wasn't a country for white people it
was a country for anglo-saxons okay they
didn't really want German German people
or Italians or Spaniards or
Scandinavians in here either so if you
want to be like really strict then
that's fine but you
say white people you're obviously
anglo-saxon at least be consistent you
know this is the problem of any legacy
almost any legacy argument that goes
back to this is what it originally was
or was meant to be there's always this
question of well where do you set the
start right like we're counting from
when is that what yes sure and and then
also the fact that like so much stuff is
pretty clearly written out in the
Constitution they're like going back to
the white thing like if the United
States was for white people why wouldn't
they write that somewhere or like if
it's supposed to be a Christian country
why would they use so much intentionally
vague language for instance like you're
endowed by their creator not by the
Creator or not by the Christian creator
like why would they use so much
intentionally vague language you know
like it just seems like your argument is
really hurting there yeah that original
constitutionalist argument is I only
ever see it being used to push like
really dumb things I don't really care
what people thought about 250 years ago
I want what's optimal for society right
now well they try to have it both ways I
feel like so for example with the Second
Amendment and guns you'll often hear the
constitutional originalist say it
doesn't matter that it was muskets and
whatever else when it was written and
that now you've got everything that we
know that that you now have they wrote
it without restrictions for a particular
reason and then in other cases they will
say no no the reason that it's vague
even though it's vague I know exactly
what was the intention well how is it
that in one case you have to go with the
literal interpretation and another one
sure you're the one who knows what the
right interpretation is yeah you can
find the original intention you know the
intention was that the Constitution has
an amendment process if we want to
change it we have the ability to amend
the Constitution I think it's pretty
dumb to say like if we were to create a
gun right now where somebody could pull
the trigger and a bullet would seek out
like a neighbor and kill them and it was
untraceable would we want that to be
legal right
probably not does it fall under the
Second Amendment I mean I guess if you
interpreted an ultra strict way it could
do you think that the founding fathers
would think that something like this is
you know a pragmatic idea to be
implemented into society
probably not there's a commercial I'm
sure you've seen it before but I it's
kind of cute the idea that um some guy
walks into a place I guess to kill his
coworker and he takes a many fires and
then he has to take out like his powder
thing and he's got it yeah right yeah
I mean like I don't know like if you
told if you tell Benjamin Franklin or
somebody you know like hey there's a guy
that in a very very tall building in the
future leans out and kills you know like
a hundred people and injures like
[ __ ] three or four hundred dudes you
know in a large city do you think that
do you think that that kind of thing
should be constitutionally protected I'm
not really sure what their answer would
be and I think you're lying to yourself
if you say oh they would definitely say
that that right should be for all people
I think you'd be lying to yourself to
say that where are you more generally on
guns I mean do you think you think
they're it's 2 lakhs I'm guessing I
don't know I don't know I love guns I'm
I've got a Mosin I've got a Glock I
enjoy shooting a lot I want to build an
AR it do you know Jeff Jefferies have
you ever heard of the guy before no no
um he's a he's an Australian he's got a
comedy skin and it's basically there are
some things that are really cool and we
wish we could do them all but that one
person [ __ ] up for all of us and we
gonna have to live with it I I think
that there something has to change with
guns in the United States that's all I
know
I don't know what the answer is because
there are already so many guns Pierre
what is it like 350 million there's more
than one gun per person in the United
States at this point but we're the only
country in the world that has this
[ __ ] up gun violence in the only first
world country like this something has to
change with that I don't know what it is
you know I would say things like you
know like greater you know like psych
evals and whatnot I think should be
really important for forgetting a fire
I'm getting a farm in the u.s. is really
easy but would that actually help
anything you know I don't I don't really
know if you look good um yeah I don't
know I'm not sure the you'll often hear
this argument from some on the more guns
and more places crowd I don't know call
them whatever you want they'll say you
know guns just aren't the problem
because in Switzerland everybody's got
guns where they all have a mandatory
conscription don't they do military now
it's like that I don't know but the gun
it's a very different situation because
the guns are kept locked up it but let's
let's grant that for a second is it
possible that the problem isn't just the
guns but it's something about American
culture and guns right and with that
argument because then they would say
well actually I totally agree with you
pac-man the problem is all the black
people that we have here that would be
their next go to yeah you might be right
you might be right but there's
definitely I mean do you see anything in
society that has put the idea in the
minds of Americans
that you can solve problems with guns
that maybe in other countries that's not
your go to right the the the the
circumstances that cause some of these
shooters call them whatever you want to
go and get a gun or multiple guns and
shoot at kill injure however many people
they do I don't think that the the
problems are unique to the United States
but I think the part that's unique is
for whatever reason thinking that the
next step is to get a gun and shoot
people as a consequence of that problem
sure so this is really hard to
understand as an American I've been over
to Germany a lot I lived in Poland for
three months this is really weird to me
but I live in Warsaw for three months
and it's like this in most of Europe
Middle Eastern Western Europe you can
walk down streets late at night and you
don't really feel like somebody who's
ever going to shoot you it's just like
in most places in Europe even in Sweden
even in Germany where all the Muslims
are taken over most people don't have
this feeling like they're going to get
shot it's just not something that most
people deal with in the United States a
guy like our art the biggest problem is
there are already so many guns here
that's the huge problem that it's much
harder to sell the argument of something
like well you don't need a gun for
instance like in Germany like you would
never say like you know why I feel like
I need a gun why the [ __ ] do you feel
like you need to got nobody else has gun
it's like people are walking around with
guns on the street whereas if you go to
the United States we go to a place like
Chicago or DC [ __ ] they're shootings
every day you know like you you know it
becomes a much more legitimate like well
I actually feel like I do need a gun
like if somebody comes to steal my [ __ ]
there's a really good chance they're
gonna have one so yeah I don't know
again going back to that I feel like
there are just so many firearms here
right now I I don't know what how you
would tell somebody you know like don't
be worried about them or what should the
solution be like it seems like a really
difficult problem to solve at this point
that's also part of the there's really
interesting work that's been done this
relates more to violence in media than
to gun specifically but there's really
interesting work that's been done by
some of the professors at my alma mater
at the University of Massachusetts like
Michael morg or char and others about
the impact of violence in media and
video games and there's this really
common usually the the debate is do does
violence in media and video games cause
people to go and MIT real-world violence
or does it not that's usually the debate
that's had but it seems that actually
the
more relevant debate is that or not even
debate but the conclusion is that
violence and video games and movies and
elsewhere makes people more afraid that
the world is more dangerous and that
they are going to be the victims of
violence when they're out in their
neighborhoods or wherever else and that
actually if people were watching a
violent movie and going out and shooting
people that would be a major major
problem but also this impact of what's
called mean world syndrome as they call
it that has a whole other set of
implications that are in a way related
to what you're saying which is people
are afraid that they're going to be
victimized whether it's by guns knives
or just other people on the street yeah
possibly yeah I'm not familiar with that
with that particular research but um
it's entirely possible you what other
issue is big for you like what what is
there anything in particular that you
think is like a issue of paramount
political importance right now
politically in the United States I guess
like I have like Trump fatigue at this
point I think that like I really did
feel like everything that Trump stood
for was like the antithesis of what it
meant to be an American I don't know if
people even care anymore like every
single day there's something new going
on with the administration that's like
impossible to believe these are all like
very important issues to me at one point
I've kind of um or they still are very
important issues to me I've kind of
focused more now on kind of dealing with
like this the Sledge of human filth that
exists on on on YouTube right now I mean
a lot of these issues right now
previously they were revolving around
things like kind of economics and
immigration and stuff like that that
we're kind of ten generally related to
race but now I've been diving more into
kind of like this race realist argument
on YouTube which is starting to become
really big unfortunately and that's kind
of where I'm focused on probably for the
next couple of months it's talking to a
lot of these people about that what do
you think about I mean I guess it'd be
interesting to get your thoughts since
you do conservatives come from the the
video gaming and streaming community
what's your sense of the impact of
gamergate which now is like several
years old do you see it as I did a bunch
of gamergate related interviews and then
I just got Terry said I don't care about
this anymore it's just like you know it
just I'm done I'm done with it and it's
instill it comes back to haunt me
interest
enough where people say hey when are you
gonna follow up on gamergate and it's
like never I'm done with it I did it in
2014 and that's kind of it but the my
question is gamergate Trump what what do
you point to as kind of like coalescing
and serving as the catalyst for this
movement on the internet that you're now
working against um I don't really know
what the catalyst would be I mean I
could make a lot of guesses but I mean I
would it would be total conjecture but I
totally saw and I've been talking about
this for a long time and I think more
people acknowledge it now
there was a totally clear crystal clear
connection from like gamergate to almost
like all right that happened and there's
a lot of articles have been written
about this like about milo gianopolous
and the way that people kind of plugged
this all in
but like basically for gamergate okay so
I'm trying to be as neutral as possible
I really do believe at one point in time
it probably started with good intentions
that there are a lot of journalists that
do a lot of really [ __ ] up [ __ ] in
gaming journalism I totally I know
that's a reality and I want to say I
really in my heart I want to believe
okay that people were really concerned
about like journalistic related [ __ ] and
gaming but somehow because of the
audience because of the type of people
that play games it was very quickly
filled up with a whole bunch of [ __ ]
women hating you know sjw hating well
you know like all of these types of
people gathered in and then once kind of
like the gamergate stuff fizzled out you
basically had this perfect political
block that was like it got co-opted by
this huge I call him the anti sjw's aka
the skeptics on YouTube you know people
like sargon of akkad people like oh god
I used to know all their names like all
of these people that are involved in
like this skeptic the the kind of likes
kept those for your Thunderfoot this the
skeptics fear movement on YouTube
basically took all of these people from
gamergate that were just kind of mad at
women and minorities I don't know people
in general but because of their video
games and then it like empowered them to
look at they they have the singular lens
of viewing the world it's like you're
either sjw or your anti sjw and like sjw
men look at all of these you know clips
from women with blue hair screaming on
tumblr aren't they all so dumb this is
what all of feminism is this is what all
of the Democrat Party is like you know
and then through there they got plugged
into like the let's get
you know the fake news fake media CNN
Washington Post all of that news is bad
and corrupt because of this headline of
this editorial we don't like so let's go
watch real news like Project Veritas and
Breitbart and articles posted on Paul
and [ __ ] you know and and you know [ __ ]
the sjw's and the right is the correct
and we're going forward into the future
and Trump represents the common man you
know this multi billionaire guy that
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the working
class you know is somehow somehow became
your represent the same group of people
that constantly said why do at least
celebrities talk about politics [ __ ]
these Hollywood cogs who elected a
celebrity you know to be the president
yeah I think there's a very clear line
that you can draw from like that early
gamergate movement to plugging them into
like this very right leading populist
conservative kind of you know think base
survey always I mean I I tend to agree
with you that game gamergate
transitioned very cleanly into support
for the all right but what I and and
I've heard this assertion refuted by
some who whatever their affiliation is
doesn't matter but the refutation has
been no there's been a survey and most
Pro gamergaters
actually identify as being on the Left
father no I does this [ __ ] all the time
people call themselves liberals now he
calls himself a liberal because he
supports health care that's cuz he's in
the United Kingdom and they have the NHS
like that'll be like the only like ah
yeah that's my biggest trigger dude is
when people say that they're a liberal
you've interviewed Dave Rubin right oh
yeah I've known I've known him for a
very very long time in the last time you
know I this is you may so to give you
the backstory because my audience may
know about this already
we were and maybe still are I guess what
you would ostensibly call friends I
don't know and I some point when the
sort of clamor grew for him to be asked
about well you say that you're on the
left and that you're a classical liberal
but classical liberalism as normally
defined is actually pretty conservative
let's ask Dave Rubin some questions so I
did an hour interview with him and to
his credit he never put any restrictions
on what I could ask it was just you want
to do an hour interview let's do it and
I did it and he and he did it and when I
heard him say something that to me
sounded inconsistent with
being on the left or had questions about
what his position is where I would sort
of challenge him on it and we basically
not spoken since and some other people
have said oh no you guys have had a
falling out this is what a falling out
is because you quest in some of those
views I don't know what the status is at
this point between Dave Rubin and I but
for we've known each other for a long
time and have been in touch for a while
so that that's the backstory to catch
you up over over the last four years I
guess mm-hmm what like the problem that
I have is when people are dishonest or
with the way that they do their content
for instance so like I consider myself
center-left
if you ask anybody let's watch my
content like oh well your senator left
what do you think of Hillary Clinton
everybody will tell you that I did not
like Hillary Clinton I absolutely hated
Hillary Clinton for a wide variety of
reasons mostly related to corporate
finance and then her wishy waviness on
on different positions and in the way
that the entire DNC was structured
partly thanks to Obama but the way the
entire way the DNC was structured for
financing Hillary's campaign and
everything and all of that [ __ ] I really
didn't like Hillary Clinton and you can
find plenty of videos of me talking
about this you know now if I go to
somebody who calls themselves a skeptic
okay if I go to any of these channels
you know I don't want to name names
because people you know get really
really triggered but if I go like any of
these skeptic channels and I say like
okay well you you you say that you're a
centrist right and they'll be like yeah
of course and then and I've done this
I've had three or four different debates
on my stream where I've talked to these
people it's like okay well you're a
centrist well let's go and see what does
your channel have to say about Donald
Trump and when you go on their Channel
every single video is making fun of
people that make fun of Donald Trump
it's making fun of people that are mad
that Trump got elected it is implicitly
defending all of Trump's views and it's
like okay how the [ __ ] can I come away
from this thinking that you don't like
for instance again to bring out a Rubin
quote he said I'll be the first one to
old Trump's feet to the fire [ __ ]
you haven't held his feet to the fire on
anything the video that Rubin put out on
criticizing the NFL players firfer for
taking the knee that was one of the
worst video ever heard in my entire life
I almost had to throw up after listening
to the the worst commentary I've ever
heard in regards to that issue but it's
yours too just to be super clear huh is
your problem with Rubin that you
disagree with it now
Caeser that you find them disingenuous I
find them disingenuous when you platform
right leaning person after right leaning
person you never challenged any of their
ideas I'm really big on responsible
platforming like you bring them one you
never really challenge them and you just
let them preach and preach and preach
and then you like implicitly or even
explicitly agree with a lot of their
things like at some point you know
Ruben's fanbase right now is not
left-leaning people you know any of
these skeptics online that call
themselves left-leaning
their fan bases are not right leading or
are not left-leaning people they're very
right leaning this is why anytime they
even remotely buck you know the
right-leaning talking points they get
crucified for it a popular example was
Dean who Thunderfoot is I do yeah yeah
Thunderfoot is a guy that built his
content around being an anti sjw but
he's actually a liberal he really is a
liberal but anytime he makes a video
talking about you know how bad a Trump
policy is his fan base like revolts like
it like the likes and dislikes are like
50/50 you know people go up in arms or
look at like Tara McCarthy or Lauren
Southern to YouTube people they're kind
of like all right white nationalist
whatever people as soon as they talk
about like hey guys um maybe we should
respect women just a little bit no
you're [ __ ] horrible
get off the car carousel you
multicultural [ __ ] what about like
their back brace goes crazy it's like
how can you be surprised that this is
the fan base that you've built when all
of your content revolves around [ __ ]
on people on the left because you
mentioned this I actually am glad you
brought this up maybe in the the sort of
in the in the wine down phase of our
conversation responsible platforming
okay I actually I've not heard that term
before and I do like it because I'm
often so dating back all the way 2010
I interviewed that guy Glenn Miller who
killed three people in Kansas at Jewish
community centers who now is he was like
a perennial Senate candidate who said
Jews and blacks or the problem he's now
doing life in prison maybe even got the
death penalty I don't know Westboro
Baptist Church people I had Richard
Spencer on not that long ago and every
time it happens there's sort of two
sides there's one side which is like any
interaction or acknowledgement of these
people is a net benefit for them and it
is giving them a platform it's
irresponsible no matter what and then
there's the sort of other side which I
tend to agree with more which is the
ideas don't disappear just because you
pretend that they don't exist and in
fact it can provide cover if people
don't know that there are these
movements these ground swells sometimes
those movements can be successful in
influencing public policy because nobody
really is even aware that they exist so
my view has always been I say interview
whoever if you believe that there's a
conversation to be had but you've got to
be prepared to make it clear where their
ideas are wrong irresponsible not based
in fact discriminatory wherever it's
that generally your view on the
interviewing of extremists yeah pretty
much and I and I am extremely in that
view I think that the idea of deep
platforming and not addressing any
arguments on the right I think was a
principal failing of Democrats in 2016
not in 2016 but in like the decade prior
they always had this idea that if we
just shame them and shun them and push
them under the carpet you know
eventually they'll go away and 2016 was
a huge wake-up call like hey they're
still there they didn't go anywhere and
they're voting you have to deal with it
whether you like it or not they're
American citizens they can vote you need
to address these ideas but I just think
that the you have to be ready to
challenge the ideas you can't just give
like a person a platform to just come on
and preach without having like anything
to say in opposition to you it would be
like do you like it wouldn't be
responsible for instance for CNN or on
Fox News to have Alex Jones come on to
do like a friendly 30 minute interview
well you don't challenge anything he
says cuz then he just comes on he's
presented a very favorable light he
probably picks up a lot of fans and a
lot of people will go over thinking
there's nothing wrong with any of the
things you know that he's saying and you
it's your job as somebody that's
platforming those people to do at least
you know a fair amount of research that
you're ready to counter you know any of
the arguments that they make that you
feel aren't morally you know acceptable
so what do you make then what do you
make then of the argument and this is
what this is on record I'm not saying
anything that people would know during
my interview with Ruben I challenged him
about that and said you know you had
david horowitz honor said obama is a
communist and you you just you didn't
say well and can you give me one example
of obama pushing communist agenda or
whatever and rubens sort of general
response has been i'm not doing this to
play point counterpoint i'm doing it so
that we can hear the set of ideas that
different people might represent how do
you respond to that idea um there's
spineless hacks is what I would call
them I hate Dave Gruber I'm sorry I
understand you might be friend somebody
hate Dave Rubin
the way this is kind of like this is the
big like dividing thing that I've owned
enough now to realize and other people
need to realize and you know people tell
me this before and I was too young or
stupid to understand it but basically
things happen whether or not you want
them to you have to understand that when
you platform somebody you can't just go
I'm just bringing them onto chat you
know if somebody you know gets you know
persuaded to their side that's not my
problem no that's a reality of the world
that we live in if you bring on somebody
that's going to preach your hateful
ideology and you don't question them on
anything then you are giving implicit
approval to it and there will be people
that are persuaded to that side now
whether or not you want to acknowledge
it it is whatever that's up to you for
how much integrity you want to have but
you can't just pretend that this reality
doesn't exist so you know like in so far
as like um in so far as Ruben saying
well I'm just getting the ideas out
there it's like okay well what do you
personally think it is morally
acceptable you know what do you have any
moral values or do you have anything
that you feel you know strongly in you
know do you think you Ruben is gay right
you know would you platform somebody
that legitimately thinks that gay people
should be executed and not question them
on anything but just kind of like
cheerily let them give their point of
view and then you know kind of laugh and
smile and then have them off knowing
that there are people watching that
program who will go and investigate the
content later and think that maybe
they're okay I mean that's your
responsibility whether you like it or
not you have a responsibility as a
public figure to some degree of the
public discourse and it doesn't matter
if you accept that or not it's just a
reality you mentioned earlier that you
see Ben Shapiro as sort of outside of
the he's not under this general umbrella
that we've been talking about for well
he's not alright as what I said he's
he's not over that I'm sorry yeah you
said he's not alright what's your sense
of him I mean I I know him a little bit
I've had him on the show we email back
and forth every once in a while I think
that much the same way that I believe
that Karl Benjamin sargon of akkad
audience is at least somewhat influenced
because at least his American audience
because he has a British accent and that
just from what it sounds like
perspective is sort of appealing to some
people I think Shapiro talking very fast
and having the appearance of being ultra
confident also to a lot of people give
the impression that his arguments are
stronger than they are oh for sure he's
I hate to overuse this I don't wanna say
that he's dumb but he plays very fast
and loose with facts I
he's like my he's like my dream final
boss where like I really want to get
into a conversation with him because I
see people that talk to him that just
aren't really equipped because he hold
machine gun fire out these he's like
really bad talking point so you can kind
of get overwhelmed really quickly
because he he puts together arguments
like in a logical way they're just very
unsound they're often built on on really
faulty premises and he's very
intimidating to talk to because you know
he sounds very confident he seems like
you know but like the the when he talks
about things it's just he just commits
some of the worst when he was doing the
gun thing just really bad statistical
errors you know like grabs where you
have like absolute numbers versus
percentages and stuff like just really
stupid things where it's like um what
was it I remember in the gun thing like
he had a graph of like well look you
know and it had to do with like the
percentage it had to do with like the
relative percentage of gun owners versus
like gun crimes and it's like the
percentage of gun owners had fallen but
the gun crimes had increased but it was
like an absolute number of gun crime so
it was always going to be increasing and
it's like if you know what you're
talking about you just look at like a
couple of these things that Shapiro
engages and it's like dude you're a hack
why are you even presenting this as fact
this was stupid there's this super
effective one where so he was speaking
at a college or something and the topic
of transgenderism came up and the
college to college video the college
speaking to her thing is a whole other
thing for it for maybe a day but and
there was a question about like why
don't you think transgenderism is
legitimate and he said something I'm
paraphrasing but it was something like
why aren't you forty years old I
remember I know I went through this
exact video in my stream and it was good
fallacious argument after fallacious
argument after fully like and there was
something like we could go through
Wikipedia know like him he said like
well this wasn't always a problem you
know like this appeal tradition okay
well you're Jewish aren't you like do we
really want to appeal to like past norms
for how to treat people like you
yourself have to acknowledge that that's
a really bad idea you know like that's
like so like you're just and it's like
just machine-gun firing out these super
ones like well you know people post-op
transgendered people still commit
suicides at higher rates oh no people
okay sure but it's not as much as people
that are pre-op you know like why don't
you acknowledge that you know I I can't
the
have you ever watched his most popular
video and how he defines like radical
Islam
you know I saw it a while ago but I
don't remember like what the highlight
of it is it basically it's it's an
entire video where he butchers stats to
try to show you that like two-thirds of
the Muslim world are like radicalist and
it'll be like he like picks and chooses
like random little poll data points from
like different countries so like for one
country he might say this percentage of
people believe that a woman's place is
in the household are like this
percentage of people believe in Sharia
law you know without understanding well
Sharia law that means a lot of [ __ ]
different things you know or or they
might even say that Sharia law should
only apply to Muslims but he'll still
pick out that stack and then by the end
of it he gets to this final number where
he's like oh well see I proven that two
thirds of the Islamic world is you know
extremist fundamentalists and it's like
really dude do the same comparison for
Christians now okay and then tell me
what you tell me what you come up with
this let's be fair with the data been oh
god yeah it's and that a let's save the
college speaking tour thing for next
time but a point point taken listen
we've been speaking with Steven Bunnell
known to some of you as destiny thanks
to everybody who watched and thanks to
you for doing this by the way I've been
sort of aware of your work for a while
and recently I actually think it's
because of being tagged into something
with you related to some debate that
Richard Spencer was in some time ago I
don't know how but I said it we should
just do this and I'm glad that we did
yeah well I appreciate it it was yeah a
lot of fun